three Russians and a Ukrainian charged
in the missile attack on flight mh17
over ukraine and the four persons are
Igor girkin Sergei Dubinsky Oleg bullet
of and Leonid Kharchenko the
announcement in the Netherlands followed
a five-year investigation into the
downing of the Malaysian airliner it
crashed in a war zone where
russia-backed separatists were fighting
Ukrainian forces this made an already
difficult investigation even more
complicated and the naming of for senior
Russia linked figures over more
significant the nephew of one of 10
British nationals killed in the disaster
welcomed the news I'm never ever going
to get my uncle back and that's the real
crux of this that's all ever wanted is
just my uncle's to be here was really
close to him I don't know what will
happen but at least we've had this small
step in the investigation but big step
you know getting some information about
what happened and who did this the
aircraft with 298 people on board had
been flying from amsterdam to kuala
lumper on the 17th of july 2014 it lost
contact over eastern ukraine an
international team of investigators say
a buk surface-to-air missile system
brought the aircraft down
investigators released evidence to back
up their claims this included a taped
phone call of one of the suspects
apparently asking for Russian
reinforcements and video footage of this
Russian missile launcher which they said
fired the fatal shot uncomfortable
viewing for President Vladimir Putin
who's maintained Russia's innocence I
did think pretty really does sheepish
it's not some of their teacher KGB
school
I think his view is you know admit
nothing deny everything and make counter
allegations which is what you get taught
in spy school when you're on a tight
spot a trial against the first four
suspects will start next March it's
unlikely they'll appear in court but
that's not going to stop Dutch
prosecutors from seeking justice Debora
Haim Sky News